احنا نتكلم عن منصات تواصل اجتماعيه فقد
تواجه مشكله مثلا
انهيار المنصه في فتره معينه اختفاء او
عدم عمل المنصه لمده ساعات بسيطه لكن لازم
نعرف ان ترى كل منصات التواصل اجتماعيه
ترى تواجه مشاكل في عدم عملها الواتساب
قبل فتره تعطل وتعطل فتره طويله
نتكلم عن فيسبوك تعطل تعطل فتره طويله
كانت اكثر من عشر ساعات سناب شات تعطل
تعطل فتره طويله كان اكثر من خمس ساعات
فلذلك توقف من الصلاه التواصل اجتماعيه
وارد وهو شيء طبيعي من دون لا يسرح موظفين
فكيف بعد ما يسرح موظفين اكيد ممكن يكون
في تعطل بسيط في الخدمات في اضافه خدمات
جديده لان كان اول عندك 7,000 مثلا موظف
يعمل على على مجموعه مختلفه من الخدمات
لكن الان قد يكون في تاخير في اطلاق بعض
الخدمات واطلاق بعض الشغلات يعني في تسرع
صار في اطلاق بعض المميزات في تويتر بسبب
همم قرارات متسرعه منصه يوم اطلقوا موضوع
التوثيق اللي تشتري التوثيق دولار ترى ترى
تاثيره
كان على اسواق الاسهم في شركات تم انتحال
شخصيتها في المنصه وهذا اثر على اسعارهم
ترى في شركات خسرت من مليارات وتويتر تراه
منصه تاثيره جدا عالي فلذلك قرارات متسرعه
من الشركه
كون اثرها مو بس على منصه نفسها راح يكون
اثرها على ممتد على على اسواق المال
الممتد على على شغلات جدا مختلفه في في
حياتنا فلذلك تويتر اي شخص موثق في السابق
كانت كلمته على قولتهم مسموعه الان ممكن
يكون في اهتزاز في ثقه الناس ممكن
الحسابات الموثقات ممكن يكون او تكون
المنصه الاختراقات همم
تويتر نفسها في اعداد موظفينها تم
اختراقها قبل فتره يوم تم نشر تغريدات في
حسابات مثل مايكروسوفت ابل وغيرها من
شركات ونشر تغريدات تتحدث عن همم ادخل هنا
وتاخذ عملات رقميه معينه وغيرها وفي ناس
تم الاحتيال عليهم بسبب اختراق الي صار
طبعا الاختراق صار ليس لضعف الامني انما
صار بسبب الهندسه الاجتماعيه تم الاحتيال
على عدد الموظفين على العدد الموظفين داخل
الشركه ونصر تغريدات من خلال منصه التحكم
الخاصه بشركه فلذلك تويتر في ايام عزه صار
في اختراقات ما في احد راح يكون محمي من
اختلاقات التي تصير في منصات التواصل
اجتماعيه